[Music]
still a lot of outrage about the NFL
replacement refs after three weeks of
NFL play including a famously bad call
on Monday Night Football that people are
still talking about everyone's saying
these replacement refs are an absolute
disaster well I've been looking at
footage of the replacement refs in
action in the last three weeks and I
have to agree they have not done a great
job judge for yourself okay
clap if you think it was holding all
right not bad okay now clap if you don't
think it was holding somebody please
tell me what holding is faster de France
on the deep miss number 22 what
cornerbacks always be passing a finish
no talking about okay I do not yet have
a ruling on the field but I do have this
[Music]
I now like to read from my screenplay
Adelina Patti
fade-in a movement Miranda white reps be
light pill to young man go for him black
recipe like I ain't getting involved in
it not mess up my shoes
[Music]
the beaters were love side
and that kid Gryffindor
[Applause]
you